i wanted to focus on
one particular sequence in i believe it
was
episode six i think it's one of the best
of the show it's uh the material at the
puppet show and cynthia i wanted to
start with you on that
because it's kind of a two-fold question
here but
someone can look at what you do in that
scene and be
like well it's just a reaction shot but
there's a lot of that there
and then on top of that you're also
working opposite someone who is dealing
with a very
very heavy emotional beat so what is the
experience like for you shooting all
those reaction shots and what can you do
for sarah to help support her
performance in the moment
it was very challenging i mean the uh
most of the time we were reacting to
absolutely nothing
and um you know i did my best to be
having the
best time gwendolyn briggs had ever had
in her entire life and i
gave no support to sarah whatsoever
because
if i had tried even for a moment if
gwendolyn had even for a moment
taken in where mildred was uh
she would have obviously said hey honey
are you okay
um so i was of no help at all except
maybe
in in growing mildred's sense of outrage
that how could gwendolyn be watching
something so horrific
and just laughing her laughing her butt
off
and sarah taking that to kind of the
next stage
in the restaurant it's it's an
especially challenging moment because as
an audience we get to experience that
entire story
in the puppet show and then you are
tasked with revisiting a lot of that
from her perspective in that scene so
what's going through your mind to keep
people engaged but also
add more to the story in the process
this was something we discussed on the
day where i was like do we need this
scene
because we just saw it we just saw the
whole thing
um so the solution
became about me basically talking to
camera as if it were cynthia and i have
not seen
the final final cut so i think is that
still in there where i basically i'm
looking down the barrel and then she's
looking down the barrel another
i think it was an opportunity to to
understand what ratchet's
pain was what you saw in the um
during the actual puppet show was a
response to the horror of it and yes
you know she's emotional and all that
but there's that mid
middling beat that not middling beat
that mid middle beat that happens in the
car when we're driving and gwendolyn
says pull over
who are you what are you you know it's
that beat that actually informs
and it's it's actually an opportunity
for for mildred to
put up or shut up basically for
gwendolyn to sort of say
i'm going to tell you now because
gwendolyn doesn't know what we've just
the audience
knows gwendolyn doesn't have the
information so it's actually an act of
intimacy that ratchet is sharing
with with gwendolyn that is the first
real
um allowance for that and i think that's
that's why it matters i appreciated the
the progression there
sharon i don't have a specific scene
question for you but as an animal lover
and also as someone who's just
fascinated by animal wranglers
in general i did want to ask about
working with petunia
and maybe specifically what kind of
notes that you get from an animal
wrangler that you then have to add to
the notes you're getting from your
director
petunia's name was pablo and pablo had
worked on
other big movies like pirates of the
caribbean and so forth so
um pablo is a trained professional actor
and he really is great and
has really a high level of communicative
skills
which was something that was very
intriguing for me because i had never
had the opportunity to work with primate
before i'd worked with
other animals and of course i believe
that my dog knows
everything i'm saying to him because of
the way he looks at me
but in fact pablo
did understand what i was saying to him
and
i became very friendly with his
wranglers and even with one of the
wrangler's
wife uh through the wrangler
because i i felt um
a great deal of tenderness and
friendship i would have to say
with pablo
i understand my buddy he's my little
buddy
when you mentioned pablo it kind of
surprised me i've heard that name before
i know i
like i do know pablo's work
thank you guys so much for your time
today and huge congrats to the show